kind of like Harvey meets Calvin and
Hobbes meets SCI club it deals with
Elijah woods character Ryan who is kind
of at the end of his rope in life and we
we first meet him when he's trying to
commit suicide
my character his next door neighbor
who's Jenna who's new from the Midwest
interrupts and it's like totally
frazzled was like Ryan can and we've
never met but can you watch my dog and
he turns and instead of seeing just a
cute lovable little dog he sees this big
Australian guy dressed up in a cheap dog
suit with a painted dog nose and he's
just like what's going on is he going
crazy
am I crazy but mean you don't know
what's happening I know so I run off and
he ends up getting to know my dog wolf
right tell me about drummer boy I'd like
to get to know her hold your lipstick
back in this case try me I you're not
her type
you know when I first had my first
chemistry read with Elijah and Jason and
we could not get through it we were
laughing so hard because Jason would be
like ball well well well well well
follow me like in my ear Invictus could
not keep a straight face does someone's
getting their nuts cut off he means me
you obviously haven't gotten it once I'm
in that suit I'm pretty miserable as and
so I just become Wilfred what do you say
ladies
the four of us can grab some drinks to
take that tops up when it was in a
strange sort of film for the first time
people looking at me like I hope you
know you're doing man like this is
called wolford and during the dogs to
form bonds and you look like an idiot
and then again when we saw the pilot it
was people like what are you doing and
when I was in America again recently it
was like okay good luck with the pilot
we've shot on Venice four times and each
time like there's been aa C's there that
I can't to me and they're like hey
Wilfred you know and so there's a lot of
love for the character I think all dogs
are perverts and weirdos yeah I don't
want to I don't have a dog I don't want
one I'm all dog died out from sometimes
dogs look at me I'm sure they look at me
differently like they know so you are he
speak on our behalf we were shooting at
the front of the house and I haven't
back to the street and this guy walks
past with his dog walking his dog I
didn't realize that the dog was behind
me saw the back of me and was like
freaking out and so I just turned around
I mean hello mate and he he he literally
pissed himself his tail went under and
he pissed himself look haha it's me it's
a man dog don't forget to make out with
a human in the season someone very
famous too famous wife of the famous
dude in may have used to star in tears I
fought to get that in there you know I
can people let their dogs lick them on
the mouth and a dog will like try and
get its tongue in your mouth even if
it's just like if it if you say no it'll
like wait and then it'll be like no I
wanted a relationship with a human that
allowed that to happen but when was from
wulfings perspective he's like making
out with her you know because we've done
a few takes and it was getting pretty
heavy and then I came in to talk to the
directors and stuff and I said um see I
was that the guy great I said did you
see my tongue go in the mouth they're
like no no but we know that that's going
and I got B didn't actually see go in
and they're like no I don't think we saw
it I said one more one more and so I
just really go at everything and at the
end I said after the so I said to the
person in question look I'm sorry about
that and she said he's sorry that's the
most fun I've had in years